foreign
opening the executive session on SP 58
I'm going to however recess it for about
five minutes we're waiting on a couple
more members so that we can have our
full complement to move on with this so
we're in recess for five more minutes
foreign
okay at this point I am reopening the
executive session on Senate Bill 58
and I am going to recognize
representative Stone to tell us about
the subcommittee's work and the outcome
thank you Mr chair the subcommittee met
last week and uh we spoke with several
stakeholders uh in addition we took
additional testimony
and it was very abundantly clear to both
the committee and the stakeholders that
we all preferred to go with the SB 58
Amendment for 594 10 versus going under
the 627
8A which was a mostly unfavorable due to
the concerns of use of force by
untrained individuals and being Exempted
uh
representative Muse had prepared an
okay
um at this point I would recognize
representative Muse to introduce or make
Mr chair I move Amendment uh
2023-1498h
second
would you like to speak on your
Amendment your motion I I would
um I think one of the experiences uh
that sometimes you have with a bill and
sometimes with floor amendments too is
that you may have the best intentions
when you introduce an amendment on the
floor but one of the things that the
floor amendment process does not give us
the opportunity to do is to go back to
stakeholders and to other people who
originally supported the bill to find
out if they still support the bill with
the amendment
so in effect our our subcommittee
meeting really became the public hearing
on the bill as it came through to us uh
in in the house and and I think one of
the things that we heard loudly and
clearly uh during the subcommittee
meeting uh from the folks that we were
able to question uh is that there were
some some huge concerns uh with uh with
the bill the way that it came over to us
to a point where a lot of the a lot of
the folks
um who uh who testified in front of us
had basically testified in support of
the original Bill and had actually been
involved in drafting the original
language but could no longer support the
bill as the Senate amended it
um Senator gray and his testimony to us
said his his number one objective is to
get uh a bill through that better
protects uh uh health care workers and
uh and and I think I think he talked
about getting some kind of a bill
through is is something that's
absolutely essential and I think we
agreed
uh but we also realize that given
the objections raised uh to the bill
which which included the fact that it
asked uh it would have allowed health
care workers to actually restrain
individuals into a police arrive which
could potentially set medical facilities
up for violations of CMS rules which
could jeopardize things like Medicaid
and Medicare funding
um there were some questions around the
broadness of the language uh so for
example would medical personnel be
allowed to detain people in places like
cafeterias and let's say places in a
hospital where Medical Care was not
being rendered so so essentially when we
when we looked at the bill the way that
it was originally worded along with uh
Senator rosenwald's Amendment we thought
that between the two of them they
actually strike a balance between better
protecting
health care workers but also ensuring
that mentally that that people who are
in Mental Health crisis who actually
lash out aren't in a position where they
lash out once they're calmed down and
then they find themselves carted off to
a County Jail that as we heard uh in in
testimony really doesn't have much of a
capability ability to treat them
so it it sets us up on this cycle where
we put mentally ill people in a jail
that's where they're not able to be
treated and well where can they be
treated in a hospital setting
so it's an extraordinarily tough uh
issue issue to deal with it but I think
the amendment uh the way that it uh
stands in the way that it is worded now
actually does deal with the situation in
in a Fair Way
um and uh the other thing that it does
is it narrowly uh expands more Atlas
arrest uh Powers which I think are I
think we're all
basically I think this is an area where
I think we were all in agreement we want
to be we want to be careful when it
comes to expanding this but what it does
do is it does expand it to include
um uh someone uh who actually commits a
misdemeanor or a violation uh while in
the care of a medical professional on
the premises of a residential care or
Health Care Facility through actional uh
through who through actual or threatened
violence interferes in the provision of
health care services that a licensed
professional has determined to be
medically necessary
that's how we narrow it down so I would
urge everybody to uh to please vote for
it thank you
thank you representative Stone would you
like to speak to your second
I would like to Simply add Mr chair that
uh under the amendment it would maintain
the probable cause standard
s under five uh 94 10 and I would concur
with representative Muse's assessment
thank you
um
representative Rhodes did you have a
question I did thank you Mr chairman I
would like to just thank the
subcommittee um on on the work that you
guys all did on this I am certainly in
support of the work that you did and I
just have one question that I thought of
last night when I should have been
sleeping
which was too late to bring it up but
you know when you go into a store and
there appears to be notices everywhere
that says you know shoplifters you know
used to say will be prosecuted now it
says you know may be apprehended does
anybody think that it is necessary does
this have to be posted anywhere like in
doctor's offices or hospitals that you
know there is this new law and if they
do say to somebody hey you know get
yourself together man
um does it need to be noticed anywhere
I would um
speaking for myself I I would think that
it would behoove the medical facilities
to to post such a thing I don't think
that we need to make it statutorily
mandated but I'm open to hear discussion
on if anyone's interested
representative Manion
thank you Mr chairman
I think we have to remember that
they're subject to arrest anyways this
just allows a warrantless arrest to deal
with the issue at the scene as opposed
to getting a warrant and arresting them
like we've been doing for ever so I
don't think a notice is necessary people
know that assault and criminal
threatening is a
is a crime this just allows an arrest at
the scene so
I agreed representative
well
I'm not being a police officer I look at
General Public
most of the general public think when
there's a police officer there that you
can be arrested
right A lot of people don't know that in
some cases they really need to go get a
warrant
they're just assuming oh I screwed up
here's the police officer I'm probably
going to jail so I think that's kind of
almost an understood thing that you you
muck up you're you're gonna
end up being arrested I have a friend
from the hospitals
yeah
I think that um I think that it's a tool
that the hospitals could use to uh post
at their own discretion to uh Point
people to if they start getting
unrolling that
um but we don't need to mandate it I
don't think any further discussion on
the amendment
uh representative scitec uh Mr chair
this is for my education and maybe not
uh something we need to discuss here but
present law talks about uh has committed
a misdemeanor or violation that's not in
the uh I'm reading from the amendment
but that looks like President law can
you be arrested for a violation
on a warrant yes currently is that is
that yeah
or committed in the office's presence
you can actually arrest someone for a
speeding ticket
we don't do it but uh
you know it's it's it can be done the
law allows it it's it's the way that uh
in New Hampshire current law is that
that's how you initiate a criminal
complaint is through an arrest or a
warrant
so this
seeing none I would ask to clerk to call
the role on the amendment
I share Rhodes yes
representative Wallace
representative scitec
representative pru yes representative
Moffett
yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tanzar yes
representative gathright yes
representative Muse yes representative
Brennan
yes representative Sue Newman yes
representative Schultz yes
representative Ray Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative salig yes representative
wheeler aye chairman Royce
gerbilts yes 20-0.
the amendment is adopted by a vote of
20-0 and open for further motions I rep
recognize representative Muse for a
motion
thank you Mr chair I move uh ought to
pass on SB 58 as amended second
moved by representative Muse seconded by
representative Stone
any further discussion I don't think we
need any
very good I just want to thank the
subcommittee for all their work this was
a very um difficult not to untie when it
got here from the Senate and I think you
guys did an admirable job of doing so
um so with that I will ask the clerk to
call the roll on ought to pass as
amended
chair roads yes representative Wallace
yes representative scitec
representative pru yes yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tensar yes representative
Catherine
representative Muse yes representative
Brennan yes representative Sue Newman
yes representative Chris Schultz yes
representative Ray Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative salig yes representative
wheeler aye chairman Roy gerbils yes
20-0
the bill is passed by the committee on a
um and I hereby close the executive any
of any objection to consent
no it'll be on consent I close the
executive session on SB 58.
um for the committee we this was our
last bill we are done
um I know I lied twice but this time I
really mean it this was our last bill
um
the speaker is going to allow us to work
on some retained bills in June if we
want to I'm going to speak for everyone
and say we don't want to I could have us
all come back to organize
for the subcommittees but or I could
just make them and send them out an
email what does everybody want to do do
you want to come back in June to talk
about subcommittees or would you rather
just have me do it
could could you just send us a list of
the various things and also maybe we
could submit like vacation times were
not available to make it work there'll
be no work in July or August so the
subcommittee work would not start until
September
um as far as list um we have 10 bills so
I can't really take requests
um so I'm going to just assign everybody
as as I think is best for their
because we do have quite a few there
might be something of perspects but
particular interest that somebody would
like to work on maybe yeah
if
um
if anyone's interested we could come
back and me or you could just email me
if you have a particular interest in one
of our retained bills
um
I would think sending out a list of what
the bills are so we know which ones are
retained and then if we have something
that we find all right that's what I'll
do I'll send out a list this afternoon
of all the retained bills and if you
have a particular interest I'll try to
accommodate that if not tough cookies
um and then you guys can start working
on those the chairs can contact them and
schedule dates in September to start
working on them they have to be back by
the end of November end of October I
would prefer if you got them all done in
September and then we wouldn't have a
stress to get them done all right it's
been a pleasure working with all of you
and I'll see you next time